1 1 emoción que tiene varios objetivos,
por 1 lado
es el paliar la falta de progresividad fiscal,
las pymes y los autónomos que pagan
proporcionalmente muchos impuestos
puedan, um, pagar menos.
Y que por otro lado,
las grandísimas empresas que proporcionalmente, insisto,
pagan
muy pocos impuestos, pues Sean más justos y paguen más,
como marca la Constitución española.
Ayuntamiento, que la apliquen,
tenga más capacidad recaudatoria,
el planes de empleo hasta para utilizarlo, eh.
Empaliar también la las desigualdades sociales,
tasa por utilización privativa del aprovechamiento
del espacio público.
También tocar la tasa de de Libi
que vamos de grandes superficies y grandes empresas,
el coeficiente de deliae,
o ponga el coeficiente más alto
a aquellas grandes empresas